hi I'm Christopher Hine uh so today I'm
going to talk to you about my current
fourth form um which is going to be
aggravating to tell you about because uh
at least number-wise because it's cyos
sensei's sixth form um it is my
old uh sixth form as well um I think
that's right um so so oh seventh form
yeah my old seventh form um but anyways
uh so the reason the numberings change
the forms don't change the way I've been
teaching the forms the way I've been
teaching the forms for quite a while but
I change the numbering because I start
realizing this connection is more
important than that connection and I'm
trying to create easy ways for students
to learn them so they're in bulks that
are like oh these lessons are all
contained in this form this form and
this form these lessons are all
contained in this form this form so I'm
playing with the numbers kind of
constantly as I get new students who are
like oh it's hard for them to get this
concept or actually this concept should
be more focused on here so that's why
the numberings change around I wouldn't
worry about it too much um uh this is
the form where you catch their elbows so
if you remember that that's the one
we're going to talk about today so I'm
going to get Josh over here we're going
to go to work
Josh all right so let's talk about
fourth form I'm losing my balance here I
drank too much this morning that's
that's a lie I I have no
problems anyway so um so fourth form now
um so this is the first form the way I
have them oriented where we are down in
uh jokai and dealing with someone who's
not in jokai who's about to attack us um
I used to have these later I think these
actually has the cleverest and best
answer for a Thrust coming in while
you're in jamai and I used to think of
it more well it's Advanced so it should
be later in the forums but now I think
it's just the best first thing to learn
and so that's why we're learning it also
has really good set of answers for um
them transitioning and also has the
remainder of the grappling stuff so uh
four and five will have the remainder of
our grappling stuff uh for the the Joe
so I think this is a good place right
after we get through the with the heads
up we start getting into this uh all
right so let's switch positions actually
all right so in this form and the
remainder of these forms I'll be in Joe
kamine and so this situation simple I
wasn't ready for any kind of fight or
exchange and this guy is ready and he's
going to attack me right so I'm just
hanging out here okay now Josh and we're
in Josh's range right so if Josh steps
in he can easily get me right so no
problem there um as he comes in with the
thrust I'm going to deal with it by
doing this now look this is the simplest
in my opinion best way to handle it
because it's the least likely to fail
now look a lot of times especially
because we love to hit sticks uh when
they come in we like to see this ah and
that's really great and and that is
something that can happen but it's bad
because of this right okay and also bad
because of this right he's already hit
me and then I hit him later right so so
those things are both sucky right so I
could just miss him on the thrust and he
stabs me or I could go too late and he
stabs me so those are bad however if I
leave the weapon right in front of my
body and as he comes in I just do this
uh that's a really simple deflection
very unlikely to miss that um the only
thing that could happen is I could end
up on the other side of his body and I
could turn slightly to deal with that
right and that's not that likely to
happen now when I'm doing this I'm not
targeting his stick I'm actually
targeting his front hand so as he comes
in I'm driving to his thumb now here's
another thing if I hit that thumb really
hard I might jam it mess it up and make
it difficult for him to deal with his
weapon which would be a nice exchange
for me right so as this guy's coming in
all I'm is aiming for that hand and I
push it to the side so it's not a big
hit just Glide it off to the side okay
now what would I do from here could do a
ton of stuff I can hit him with one hand
I can hit him from underneath with one
hand I can transition myself into attack
him all kinds of stuff now look if I
transition in to attack him we're
actually flip rolled for second form so
look we're close quarters and I go here
and if he did a mhi barai to get back
bang now we're in second form right so
you can see second form immediately
attaches to these forms as well okay so
I'm here what's Josh probably going to
likely want to do any of those well with
Close Quarters so if he could transition
long distance by using jod and guch then
he's going to have an advantage over me
cuz I'm definitely in a crippled
position here if we stay close quarters
it the stick's about as good for me as
it is for him he's a little bit of an
advantage but not a huge Advantage so
he'd want to get a bigger Advantage all
right so this form notices that he is
going up and sticks to those elbows and
he's going back and I drive him back
right so I want to push him off of me
now pyto Sensei shows this with a step
on the foot which I think a good idea
there's nothing wrong with that idea and
that's just real simple as he goes back
I go here boom and he's trying to step
back and you know jacks up his ankle or
whatever as I shove him back that's
really cool but honestly just shove him
way away that's the answer okay so I
shove him really far off of me so that
way his transition gets screwed up okay
now in this though when I go to shove
him away the form makes this guy a lot
stronger than me so I can't right I
tried to push him away but I can't push
him away so he's still coming in so as
he comes in I rotate to the other side
bang bang bang now in this form we're
opposite side of the way we ended three
so I'm opposite side of three but in a
very similar position to three right so
three I'd be over there uh this form I'm
over here right so if I was doing three
I would be over here and I would go into
this position right but here I'm here
now I can still do the movements from
three here so meaning if something goes
wrong with this I can still slide up
into three and do my caga and my choke
right there just as well but this is
nice because I have more access to the
inside of his arms and I take that
access also andyto Sensei specifically
says this is not what we're doing but
there are a strikes in all of those
movements so meaning after I've come to
the elbows here I have a strike here at
the back of the head boom I have a
strike here boom to the arm and then I
have a strike here that could be the
wrist this side or this side and right
now I'm just going in and controlling
the weapon so I'm in the middle of the
weapon here now I think scy the Sensei
says don't do that because he doesn't
like people bonking each other with the
stick it's rude and annoying and it
happens all the time but notice those
are in there for you so if you want
those you can use those shouldn't do it
to your training Partners all the time
okay now after this what's the guy want
to do he's going to want to clear his
weapon now the simplest way to do that
is just to pull it back like that okay
now if he pulls it really far like so if
he pulls it a little bit I could stick
with him right so there's nothing
changed there actually let's let's face
them okay but if he pulls it really far
that's great because now I have all
kinds of strikes in here and also if he
pulls it really far and we get this I'm
also set up here right so I get again my
my number three answer for that okay if
he doesn't pull it too far I just keep
my stick in there messing up his arms
now if Josh goes to hit me right now I
have one hand on this stick he push as
hard as he wants without letting go of
the weapon which is what I want because
when he lets go of the weapon I'll have
more control okay without him Letting Go
the weapon he can't get out of this
position really easily I use that to my
advantage and I just torque him that
direction right so I push him off of me
now if one of his hands pops off the
weapon that's what I want cuz he'll now
have one hand on his weapon I'll have
two hands on my weapon uh and that'd be
an advantage for me so if he wants to
let go sweet I like that if he gets
thrown away sweet I like that right so
let's just look at that face on again
real quick so face them okay so we're
here like this and I've hooked up and as
he raises all I do is keep my stick in
there that's all I'm doing is keep my
stick in there and I'm driving over if
it slipped out from under this I get
answers from either three or two right
so if Bo okay if this slipped out so he
could let go or whatever say let's go
that's cool here's the answers from
three right okay and I also get answers
from two meaning that I can come in here
and so as he comes to strike bang we get
there so if it slips out either way I
get answers from three or answers from
two he could let go my stick just slips
out whatever get answers from three and
answers from Two and that right okay so
let's look at this whole form here so
I'm not in the ready to fight position I
just happen to get my wits about me the
second he thrusts boom he decides to
transition I stick to him here like this
but but I can't shove him back so he
shifts forward so I can't shove him back
then I come back here and I can hit him
1 2 3 if I want I lock up his weapon as
he tries to clear his weapon I stick to
those hands and I push him away from me
right so this is my old seven um my uh
cyto Sensei 6th and my current four um
it really doesn't matter right so like
the these numbers are mostly just a
teaching convention that makes it easier
for me to go through this and right now
we're having a rough time because it's a
bad teaching convention CU all my
students are wait which one is this so
if you want to remember it is the one
where you catch their elbows perfectly
reasonable right now right so I'm just
streamlining the way I teach them uh as
we go so currently four um and this
teaches almost we have almost all the
grappling methods up at this point um
I'm Chris fry it's Joshua T my salon
McDaniels behind that camera right there
we'll see you in the next video